Network technologies were developed to connect
components (in this case individual computer
systems) separated by larger distances, i.e.,
distances measured in meters instead of centimeters.
Communicating over these larger distances
led to different design tradeoffs.
In early networks, information was sent as
a sequence of bits over the shared communication
medium.
The bits were organized into packets, each
containing the address of the destination.
Packets also included a checksum used to detect
errors in transmission and the protocol supported
the ability to request the retransmission
of corrupted packets.
The software controlling the network is divided
into a "stack" of modules, each implementing
a different communication abstraction.
The lowest-level physical layer is responsible
for transmitting and receiving an individual
packet of bits.
Bit errors are detected and corrected, and
packets with uncorrectable errors are discarded.
There are different physical-layer modules
available for the different types of physical
networks.
The network layer deals with the addressing
and routing of packets.
Clever routing algorithms find the shortest
communication path through the multi-hop network
and deal with momentary or long-term outages
on particular network links.
The transport layer is responsible for providing
the reliable communication of a stream of
data, dealing with the issues of discarded
or out-of-order packets.
In an effort to optimize network usage and
limit packet loses due to network congestion,
the transport layer deals with flow control,
i.e., the rate at which packets are sent.
A key idea in the networking community is
the notion of building a reliable communication
channel on top of a "best efforts" packet
network.
Higher layers of the protocol are designed
so that its possible to recover from errors
in the lower layers.
This has proven to be much more cost-effective
and robust than trying to achieve 100% reliability
at each layer.
As we saw in the previous section, there are
a lot of electrical issues when trying to
communicate over a shared wire with multiple
drivers and receivers.
Slowing down the rate of communication helps
to solve the problems, but "slow" isn't in
the cards for today's high-performance systems.
Experience in the network world has shown
that the fastest and least problematic communication
channels have a single driver communicating
with a single receiver, what's called a point-to-point
link.
Using differential signaling is particularly
robust.
With differential signaling, the receiver
measures the voltage difference across the
two signaling wires.
Electrical effects that might induce voltage
noise on one signaling wire will affect the
other in equal measure, so the voltage difference
will be largely unaffected by most noise.
Almost af bus architecture proved to be
a very workable design for accommodating add-in
cards as long as the rate of transactions
wasn't too fast, say less than 50 Mhz.
But as system speeds increased, transaction
rates had to increase to keep system performance
at acceptable levels, so the time for each
transaction got smaller.
With less time for signaling on the bus wires,
various effects began loom large.
If the clock had too short a period, there
wasn't enough time for the master to see the
assertion edge, enable its drivers,
have the signal propagate down a long bus
to the intended receiver and be stable at
each receiver for long enough before the sample
edge.
Another problem was that the clock signal
would arrive at different cards at different
times.
So a card with an early-arriving clock might
decide it was its turn to start driving the
bus signals, while a card with a late-arriving
clock might still be driving the bus from
the previous cycle.
These momentary conflicts between drivers
could add huge amounts of electrical noise
to the system.
Another big issue is that energy would reflect
off all the small impedance discontinuities
caused by the bus connectors.
If there were many connectors, there would
be many small echoes which would could corrupt
the signal seen by various receivers.
The equations in the upper right show how
much of the signal energy is transmitted and
how much is reflected at each discontinuity.
The net effect was like trying to talk very
fast while yelling into the Grand Canyon.
The echoes could distort the message beyond
recognition unless sufficient time was allocated
between words for the echoes to die away.
Eventually buses were relegated to relatively
low-speed communication tasks and a different
approach had to be developed for high-speed
communication.e at both ends.
What this model is telling is the time it
takes to transmit information from one component
to another and that we have to be careful
to absorb the energy associated with the transmission
when the information has reached its destination.
With that little bit of theory as background,
we're in a position to describe the real-world
consequences of poor engineering of our signal
wires.
The key observation is that unless we're careful
there can still be energy left over from previous
transmissions that might corrupt the current
transmission.
The general fix to this problem is time, i.e.,
giving the transmitted value a longer time
to settle to an interference-free value.
But slowing down isn't usually acceptable
in high-performance systems, so we have to
do our best to minimize these energy-storage
effects.
If the termination isn't exactly right, we'll
get some reflections from any voltage step
reaching the end of the wire, and it will
take a while for these echoes to die out.
In fact, as we'll see, energy will reflect
off of any impedance discontinuity, which
means we'll want to minimize the number of
such discontinuities.
We need to be careful to allow sufficient
time for signals to reach valid logic levels.
The shaded region shows a transition of the
wire A from 1 to 0 to 1.
The first inverter is trying to produce a
1-output from the initial input transition
to 0, but doesn't have sufficient time to
complete the transition on wire B before the
input changes again.
This leads to a runt pulse on wire C, the
output of the second inverter, and we see
that the sequence of bits on A has been corrupted
by the time the signal reaches C.
This problem was caused by the energy storage
in the capacitance of the wire between the
inverters, which will limit the speed at which
we can run the logic.
And here see we what happens when a large
voltage step triggers oscillations in a wire,
called ringing, due to the wire's inductance
and capacitance.
The graph shows it takes some time before
the ringing dampens to the point that we have
a reliable digital signal.
The ringing can be diminished by spreading
the voltage step over a longer time.
The key idea here is that by paying close
attention to the design of our wiring and
the drivers that put information onto the
wire, we can minimize the performance implications
of these energy-storage effects.
Okay, enough electrical engineering!
Suppose we have some information in our system.
If we preserve that information over time,
we call that storage.
If we send that information to another component,
we call that communication.
In the real world, we've seen that communication
takes time and we have to budget for that
time in our system timing.
Our engineering has to accommodate the fundamental
bounds on propagating speeds, distances between
components, and how fast we can change wire
voltages without triggering the effects we
saw on the previous slide.
The upshot: our timing models will have to
account for wire delays.
In Part 1 of this course, we had a simple
timing model that assigned a fixed propagation
delay, t_PD, to the time it took for the output
of a logic gate to reflect a change to the
gate's input.
We'll need to change our timing model to account
for delay of transmitting the output of a
logic gate to the next components.
The timing will be load dependent, so signals
that connect to the inputs of many other gates
will be slower than signals that connect to
only one other gate.
The Jade simulator takes the loading of a
gate's output signal into account when calculating
the effective propagation delay of the gate.
We can improve propagation delays by reducing
the number of loads on output signals or by
using specially-design gates called buffers
(the component shown in red) to drive signals
that have very large loads.
A common task when optimizing the performance
of a circuit is to track down heavily-loaded
and hence slow wires and re-engineering the
circuit to make them faster.
Today our concern is wires used to connect
components at the system level.
So next we'll turn our attention to possible
designs for system-level interconnect and
the issues that might arise.